he
is a loner a big fat
loser a coward and a pathetic
human being defiant in the faith they
were targeted for
of the victims of a terrorist
coward rotten devil
this is what they call the murderer who
massacred 51 people
in two christ church mosques last march
your father was a garbage man
and you became trash of society
he is ashamed of your identity
you deserve to be buried in a landfill
their loss is profound
lives change forever by injury
others by death the last words i'll hear
from sire
for now were calling me
oh how i regret not doing that the last
time i saw him alive
when he left for school their faithful
mind
i love you cyan
my angel a child
stolen
my father
the apple of our eyes opted for that
costume
hear the name a parent
gone i wonder if he was in pain
if he was frightened
and what his final thoughts were brenton
tarrant will be sentenced tomorrow for
51 murders
40 attempted murders and a terrorist
charge
[ __ ] mohamed nabi was one of those
he's shot dead i would like to say that
my 71
year old dad would have broke you in
half
if you challenged him to a fight
but you are weak
a sheep with a wolf's jacket on
for only 10 minutes of your whole life
those targeted in the attack today
walked freely in the sunshine
something the terrorist will likely
never do again
siobhan robbins sky news